好 谢谢大家时间
然后报告前两个星期没有update
就有点忙 然后事情没有update
但是我其实在推特上也讲了很多关于这个市场
就是什么去数筹码 怎么看似贴
其实市场在过去两个星期是违反
就是那个重上一星期 违行的反弹
然后现在这么说可能有点马后炮吧
但是本质我们来看这个市场从上两周
已经比较明确的能够看到很多那个叫position
就是市场仓位的指标在非常明显的偏向于多头
就是偏向于多头或者是上下的风险不平均嘛
叫做不均衡的风险
其实压住多头是相对来说安全度很高
那我觉得我接下来今天要讲几个事情吧
第一个回顾一下过去这两周的市场
就是我为什么不能懂
回顾一下过去两周的市场
然后这两周过去一周反弹
其实再加上上一个月
我们一直看到这个市场在下跌
然后砸牌的力量为什么没有砸得动
然后接着就是说一下接下去一周一两周
我们现在只能看到一两周
一两周流动性的情况
我觉得总体先说一下结论
就是接下去两周市场还是偏向于非常偏向于多头
我觉得今天讲这个时间时间上是比较有利的
因为我们看到的扭转点在上个星期
流动性的扭转点在上个星期
但是扭动性特别充裕的点在这个星期
然后可能会 turn around 的时间
大概是在下下周就下周末一点
或者再往下一点时间
因为后面有很多我们叫做 fact dependent
有很多很多因素会影响他
特别是美国和伊朗在或是穆斯凯范加那个纷争
后面会不会打起来
或者会有很多的不确定性
那确实包括政治上的不确定性都在都在这个事情上
但是我们可以说从这个星期来看
其实不确定性不是特别的
就是虽然他周末谈奔了
那我我其实在周末的时候
可能不少投资人也在说到这个问题
周末谈奔其实不是一个特别大的影响
然后我会说为什么
然后先说一下上一周
为什么市场经历了一个比较
最后我如果有时间的话
我可能讲几个投资单独的标的
然后以后我们每周都会可能讲几个
然后这一周我想本来是讲一下那个
讲一下 note care 然后这个可能关注关注我的
我经常过大致讲过一些
然后有一些朋友我也发过一些报告给他
然后我会大概讲一下
为什么是note care这个标的
然后或者讲一下amd
这两个都是我比较看好的
然后接着就是上一周
为什么有这样的反弹
其实是相当于我们在三个星期前
一直在说虽然我们比较看好市场
然后也看好token的需求
也看好AI的需求
这非常非常缺货非常严重
但是那个卖牌的压力
因为从去年年底到今年年初
一直涨不上去
整个市场其实本质上是涨多了
涨得太快
然后涨太快之后
它涨不上去
导致CTA的投算要逆转
这个逆转带来的卖牌压力
是史上非常非常高
整个卖牌有多少
就过去一个月吧
总的卖牌从2月份开始可能更多
但是过去一个月
抛掉上个星期
卖了180个别链就1800银
这个力量是极大的
就是能够让这个市场炸下去
然后突破了一些关键的点位
就CTA看的关键点位
这个可以回顾一下
我们上两周讲
就是大概6700 6600这样
这样两个SMP的点位
而且是Global CTA
可能卖出的幅度可能更大
等一下
Global CTA卖出的其实幅度相对来说
是更加大一点的
然后美国中间占一半
那美国在里面可能占了80到90
所以看到大规模的卖牌
然后加上我们看到Historic
就历史最高的Prime Book
历史上最高的Prime Book做空
这个是到4月9号位置
Prime Book做空
我们叫Zesco
就是有多少个方差
就是因为统计上
你不能够把17年的水平
和现在这水平做比较
对吧
那你做空其实是看有多少个方差做
就是方差就是什么
就统计上的有多么异的极端
就是说Zesco的话
是历史上相对来说是最高的Prime Book的做空
做空的量一直从去年开始累积到现在
在一个非常高的位置
所以空头是极其拥挤的在4月9号之前
极其拥挤的空头
其实它还有的就是CTE一直给它注然
所以它能够把市场往下砸
但是砸的幅度比我们在春节前后预期的小很多
后来我有回顾了一下
为什么
在春节前后
我其实觉得可能会砸到10到15
就是一个比较健康的修复
要10到15
然后到大概6300
其实到6300
就是至少要到6300左右
那为什么其实没有砸洞
很多票没有砸洞
那个最主要的原因
我觉得是四个方面
第一个就是美股整体的估值已经很低了
其实你看那些大票
包括像比较说软件相关
比较说microsoft甚至meta和那个除了不够以外
除了Google Tesla
这是个神奇的票的
然后Tesla Google以外
包括在英伟达
包括在Microsoft Amazon
那个Meta或者是苹果还算可以
但是基本上大票都是这样
就是它的估值已经低于去年4月份
就是因为去年业绩增长了
你的股价都没有增长
股价还跌了
估值打了很低
所以你继续往下打的这个空间很少
就单票来说
你本身这个
因为主要大市值的公司压加在哪里
你从英伟达来说
英伟达去年业绩增长70%
其实你equivalent相比较的话
现在的股价
就前一段时间
你股价已经打到了4月份90块钱的
这个价格了
所以估值低
本质上就让整个市场跌不太动
然后第二个就是
青年年初到去年年底没涨动的
一个很大原因就是对于AI的富裕期
AI的富裕期来自于对于
大的hyperscale的他们的naked cash
就是free cash will變少
也就是你没有过的钱
我预期你后面可能就没有办法做
做过的capax
这个华尔街的assumption就是
预期在那里
就是有没有道理
我们晚点再说
我觉得其实不一定有道理
因为第一个
它很多的可以融资的渠道没有打开
第二很多的钱是来自于工资的
就比较残忍的说
就是把这些人都砍掉
因为现在你看到比较说
欧罗克已经在干这些事情
他有那么多砍人
然后人是脱利生产力的最大的
脱利
就是你这些工作不需要
那些人不挨贵过多少贵的
然后把这些人砍掉
富裕开始说好一点
所以富裕期其实打满
然后对于AIinfra
其实大家都不太买账
其实对于华尔街来说
就是你钱从哪里来
然后接着第三个就是打不动的原因
还有就是富裕期打满的情况下
AI的需求其实非常
AI和infra的需求其实是很足的
那一方面看到我不相信也
然后我不相信他能投那么多Kapex
另外一方面
我们看到最于token的需求
省纸数计量的在上升
你们最近如果经常在用
那个cloud的人
应该其实是知道的
经常用cloud的人
你会发觉cloud的最近一直卡
对吧
你把 afro调成max
有人说cloud的降制
我就降制到还好了
你把afro调成max的话
你会发现他经常就会卡一下
然后那个经常就是给你断一下什么之类的
其实这个背后是
是anthropic
希望把token卖更贵
其实不是
anthropic没有算力了
那个在所有的算力中心
就所有的这个AI公司
就是AI的需求里面
其实算力需求是最最指数计的在增加的
这个东西每年4倍
而且它是直接产生生产效率的
所以是非常刚性的一个需求
在推动生产基础设施的建设
这个和互联网时代
这个基础设施建设是不同的
互联网时代是我需要
一定要有连接
然后我要司科去把这个基站给建了
建了以后其实使用率并不高
现在的商业的模式
AI时代的商业模式
和软件时代的商业模式
或者说互联网时代的商业模式的本质不同
是当时是药厂模式
也就是说我建完
我要有
然后我的软件也得我得有
有了之后我可以继续去卖
我可以不停的把它Copy分离去卖
SARS公司都是卖软件
但是它对于Infra
对于基础设施的这个需求
它并不是指数级的不停的在上升
它需要每个地方都有基站
当我讲到诺基亚的问题
也是Typical的在上一个周期的一些资源的利用
其实给诺基亚带来很多机关
就比方说我的基站
那个4G网络5G网络
我需要在每一个基站里大量的配电
那个配电是可能是10%真正在应用
它是按照最大需求来配的
但是它是不满的
但是你在AIInfra这个过程中间
因为它不是一个药厂的模式
它是一个工厂的模式
也就是你电进去以后
它要变成token出来
在电视消耗
你每一次跟它对话
其实都在相当于是利用工厂的干活
你都要付钱的
所以就是整个行业从一个亲资产
转化为众资产的过程中间
生产 众资产 生产资料这些公司
它其实没有得到足够的固执
就是一方面我们不相信它要做很多开拍
另外一方面
其实看到了无限的这个token需求
这两个矛盾点
然后市场其实跌不下去的
因为我很清楚看到这个需求很大
然后最近很多人在炒存储
也是一个道理
从中国看到它明年后年
这个需求放在那里
Ned的需求或者现在大家所存储场
已经到了我consumer
就是我们家做手机的做车的
以前是我客户
我得候着它
现在你就不是我客户
你I去哪去哪
然后我现在就服务算一中心就行了
就是整个算力从点到端
这手机要点自己的点
然后到端到云端
这个大的shift
然后大的这个需求
需势放在那里
就是也让市场跌不下去
这个都是我们之前说过的
然后看多市场原因
然后第三个
第四个就是经济基本面
就我们周五报了CPI
CPI其实我觉得还是相对的
说比较良心的
然后看到美国
我觉得还是基本的
美国经济的基本面
维持我们之前看了
就是它的通胀
尽管有油价的影响
最多就是油价涨百分之一百
对那个油价相反
就油价涨上去
每百分之十
数学公式下0.04
对于核心CPI影响
但是核心CPI没有发现
工资螺旋上涨的影响
上一次能防肥肉比较好
前一次比较差
然后一月份有比较好
跟劳工部调了很多
参数预期是有关的
就是它的Death Birth Rate
那被调整以后
其实对那个
我们看那个整个就业的东西
要看它就业的趋势
就业的趋势在AI的这个
第一个AI这个冲击下面
第二个
第一个AI的冲击下面
其实第二个就是经济基本面上
我们会看到
经济基本面是相对比较良心
就是GDP增长比较良心
甚至上一期GDP增长
都远远不及预期
然后那个通胀不会特别高
因为你失业的情况是会比
失业的情况
会比经济基本面还稍微差一点
所以我们待会讲连储预期的时候
我就会觉得
每连储今年还是很有可能会讲信
Kallen Walsh认命这个不会最终
不会是因为
就会中间在议会上面会吵
到底DOU界就是那个
DOU界就是司法部
是不是把那个JPEL的案子给drop掉
然后把那个Kallen Walsh认命
但Kallen Walsh上台
他既然作为特朗普兄弟的儿子
他上台的任务应该去降息
所以你对于美联储的政策
是不是QT这个Protestide
大家都觉得他会QT
把这个事情放开
但是他降息肯定会降
所以
政策流动性的政策是会
我觉得偏松的
所以经济资本面是偏良性的
然后估值比较低
富裕期打满了
然后AI的需求很大
这三方面让整个市场没有跌动
这个市场经历了
最大固定模的对冲基金的买出
建立了空舱
然后经历了CTA的大量的空头
卖了1800亿
没有杂动的时候
反弹就会非常剧烈
这反弹并不能完全
不应于美国和伊朗会核弹好
其实他核弹好
核弹不好
包括中国核弹没有弹好
对吧
他一样要涨
因为背后的买盘力量太确定了
那我们说一下
CTA的买盘
它在什么规模
这个CTA的买盘
也就是这个星期
你可以看到在Global
有对涨跌影响是蛮大
就Global的全球来看
是Flatcase和不是Flatcase
买盘是有影响
但是对美国
你看最上面这个S&P美国
你涨还是跌
你哪怕跌2.5个时间的Nivation
他买还是要买21个别链
然后如果Flat的话
买32个别链
这个是Global统计的数据
不一定特别准
但是基本上就在这个Range
在这个范围里面
全球要买正常情况
想要买80个别链
这个量会非常大
就是而且这个量没有结束
因为接下去
从4月9号往后一个星期
就是我们这个星期开盘
到后面这一个月
是买1000亿 1200亿
就是在市场持平的时候
但是买1200亿
它不很难持平
所以大概率有它会满足更多
所以在这个比较大的买盘下面
其实我们看到Position买盘
预期这么明确的情况下
Prime不过就N1了
所以在对冲基金
上个星期并不是CTA推动的
CTA大概一个就买了10个别链
我刚刚讲是买了10个
美国的话就买了10个别链
Global就大概买了15个别链
就是一百五十一百
但是Primebook经历了大规模的平仓
所以我们开SNP的return的话
一个星期百分之七
是历史上很高的位置
但是有没有结束呢
因为你前面的砸盘
其实理论上应该把它砸得更低
就是能够砸出更大的SNP的DF
那么没有
但是接下去这一周
包括下面的买盘就非常确定性
还是很高
所以我觉得看多第一个是CTA的买盘
Primebook已经N1了
然后第二个
就是我们叫做Foundamental的
就是基本面的
就Long Only Fund
没有大规模买路
Long Only Fund的买路大概打三分了
十分里面打三分在上个星期
其实大家还在观望美国和伊朗
在霍尔·霍斯木斯海下
到底会搞成什么样子
就是周末听了不少
包括投行和基金层面
对于伊朗形势的判断
大家讨论
在星期天Vance所谈崩了之前
其实没有一个人真正觉得
这一次就握手美国和伊朗
40年的恩怨
然后就一字化解
然后就达成底有
没有一个有这样的预期
首先就是伊朗这一边
其实它是非常分裂的
I-LGC的目的是永久执政
它掌握了全国50% 40%以上的财政资源
就是它是一个非常腐坏的军政府
它这个军队经商
真拿了国家40%的资源和油的资源
这帮人自费非常非常有钱
小孩都在美国
然后最近还被赶回来了对吧
然后他们其实对抗美国要强硬
其实是需要一个
因为伊朗国内的名声
英国上斯大陀查以后
伊朗国内的名声对它已经非常反感
它需要一个正义的口号
说明我是正义的
我反美
然后我保卫国家利益
所以我要永久执政
我得有个大意在那里
所以有这个大意能够跟美国附软
面上附软
就是不太会跟面上附软
但是它其实
IogC
其实伊朗也不是很想跟
也不是很想当其他国家的前往
就是跟美国真正打下去
他能够在今天跟美国说不
其实背后看穿的是美国的国内的政治
其实他们也不傻
美国国内政治情况
特朗普因为发动了这次战争
他的支持率跌完这次
所以你可以看
Polymarket之前认为
Congress的选举
就是参院的选举
共和党是基本上是肯定赢的
然后觉得
Condrest
Senate是共和党基本上肯定
Condrest是要输给Democrat
输给民主党
但是Polymarket上
从上个月已经开始逆转了
觉得你两院都要输掉
就共和党可能两院都要输掉
两个议会都要输掉
那么
这个跟川普背后的支持率下降有关
而且川普背后支持率下降很明显的
是他的MACA基本盘
是GOP的基本盘
在开战的时候
GOP的支持率是很高的
MACA的支持率很高的
但是打到现在的话
MACA日本盘
就是他的最最
就是Make American Great Again
这帮红脖子
对他的支持率在下降
GOP的支持率下降
所以特朗普不管是出于美国
其实也不完全出于美国原有的原因
因为美国其实并不缺油
对吧
但是出于自己身的政治考量
他非常想把这个战争结束
然后第二个
他在国会要获得国会的批准
去打这个仗
因为他两个月以后
他可以紧急出兵
但他两个月以后
他一定要挺站
国会有这个要求
就是你必须要过国会
过国会是不可能的
肯定过不了
然后肯定过不了的情况下
那个他三个月
其实必须要结束战争
特朗普有没有可能通过紧急法案的方法
我就是要把这个仗打下去的
是可以的
但是这样就变成他一个人的战争了
就是你冒着违反议会的决议
冒着违宪的原因
然后你去打了这个仗
如果没打好
那所有责任全是你的
在政治上
他很难做这样的决策
而且中纪权局在那里
就是国内民意
又不在他这边
他一个人顶着风干这个事情
对他没有好处
所以他非常想结束这个战争
伊朗其实也看穿了这个一点
就是不想在台湾桌上
让出太多的东西
但是同样
就是我对一个经济这个形势的判断
就是你接下去的时候
伊朗会不会升级
美国把海洋海洋
就是你你你封不怎么打
对吧
我把你会怎么打也封了
封了以后
你的原油都出来了
中国的油也进口不了了
中国今天早上游船过去
已经特朗普掉头回去了
不管国防部多么强
也没有用
你在这个船你就是过不去
对吧
好
那伊朗的经济
就在处于一个崩溃边缘
那大家就熬嘛
看谁能够撑到撑到那个那个那个点
但是会不会继续升级
比方说美国真的去炸他的电站
炸他的桥梁
或者陆军登陆
我个人觉得很难
就是创伯没有没有必要再再冒这个风险
然后伊朗会不会升级
比方说把导弹打到
然后科威特的淡水精华的地方
我觉得也不会
他这样做是逼着欧盟参战
然后逼着美国的国会批准
对他没有任何好处
其实最好的就是大家互相骂
然后这件事情不了了之
大家就是慢慢 de-escalate
慢慢的降级
我觉得这个可能是比较大的
所以在这种情况下面
就是我们如果只要不要发生特别极端的事情
在未来一个星期
你们可以看到这个买盘的需求就特别大
然后最后再讲一个就是流动性的问题
这个流动性的问题
可能说也是相对来说比较重要的
然后你可以看
我这边好像漏掉一个图
没关系吧
流动性其实从利率市场来看
就是我们说利率对资本市场影响
对于股票市场影响是利率上涨
一般性涨到利率上涨
对股票市场影响比较负面
但是之前也经常讲过
影响最负面的不是利率本身
而是利率的波动率
也就是说我从4.1
慢慢涨到4.3
4.4
4.5
它对市场影响是负面
但是不是很大
但是它从4.1
猛升到4.2
那这个影响就很负面
就是这个叫rate wall
我们在上周看到rate wall整体下跌
而且下跌幅度很大
因为之前我们认为这个rate wall
有点太过分了
然后rate wall下跌
就是下跌幅度很大的
是两个standard deviation下跌的
就是我们叫方尚瓦两个z score下跌
所以看到rate wall下跌
对资本市场本身就是一个很大的support
然后市场的流动性特别好
市场流动性从上个星期来
它有上个星期五
上个星期四的时候
suffer rate和发放rate之间
差了a to ba basis point
IORB是那个等于是发放swap
然后一般来说
你suffer是等于repo rate
是那个回购率
回购你等于是
就你怎么说
你平台每连出利率的吧
你承担的这个风险
是等于银行间的
就制压的这个风险
其实你怎么说
你不能够比每连出利率低
但是suffer rate就是上周的话
就是比那个更低
然后这个表明银行间流动性极为关于
然后这么多流动性中间的一天
就是daily跑出去
15个别人到RRP里面
RRP是reverse repo
reverse repo是当时在说点白管
因为大家可能不同的白管不一样
但是说那个
当时在疫情的时候
每天处放了太多的钱
然后放了太多钱以后
因为流动性实在过于宽语
使得没有人愿意把钱放给money market
放这个流动性
就利率太低了
没有人愿意把钱放给money market
然后导致money market
融不到钱以后
整个是流动性市场反而崩溃
所以每连储就是贴补货币市场基金
然后成立RRP pro玩
然后让货币货机可以把钱放到
每连储
然后获得利息
那你想
如果他的利息suffer rate是低于
那个连储的基转的话
那他货币货机的话
就是免费free money
就是免费ABS point不多
但是他不量大
可以获得一些free money
但是这个钱RRP
更像一个流动性的蓄水池
就是当其实RENI
就是疫情那一波的流动性在RRP里面
但最后累计到2万多亿
然后这2万多亿的东西
一直放出维持了一年半
就是给市场一直在数学
然后Prototype
这是以前的故事
但是上一周发生的事情
就是流动性市场过剩
然后又重新回流到RRP里面去了
那么这个过程
会不会直到这个星期
这个星期我觉得也是这样
所以整个市场
在短期里面看流动性
就是过于快于
太多钱
CTA要买
那个Primed Book要N-Wide
狼翁里还在等
他没买
他们还有可能会买进来
然后Valray的下降
所以在整一套组合权的情况下
市场流动性是过剩的
就是我们可以无视
伊朗谈成什么样子
这个事情无关
然后我觉得
就是这一周不是会需要太担心
但是从下周和再下周
或者下周晚一点
我们会看到美国要收税
然后收税的时候
这个钱流向是从商业银行
去交到国家
国家Trustry
然后Trustry把这个钱存在美联储
相当于变相的从市场抽走流动性
在Taxi的解锁的时候
可能会少掉4000多亿Bank result
这个是大家要注意的一个信号
虽然后面CTA也要买
但是市场流动性可能不会像现在这么宽语
但是会有多大的负面影响
我觉得未必会很大
因为现在流动性是过于宽译
但是这个流动性恢复正常的话
在下下周可能会复正常
那要看这两周涨太多
是不是会涨太多
这两周如果涨了很多
就有反向一样
就拉盘一下子拉了很高
然后拉盘力量下降的时候
这个时候就是要拧起注意的
所以我觉得注意的点
可能在下周晚一点或者在下周
那么短期的一个拉盘的调整
可能在那个位置
但是这一周
如果我觉得钱是苹果身
就钱这样的
然后最后5分钟
我本来想讲一下
可能时间不够多了
把很多东西来不讲
然后我讲一下软件和业绩和软件
和这些东西
对冲基金做空
美国的软件是很明显
我之前说过
就说软件业绩都没有什么问题
包括你像前两天被砸了
昨天反弹
前两天被砸了
很凶的net
这cloth
这种是一个非常标准的案例
还有10分钟
我再加5分钟
然后这是一个非常标准的案例
然后就是说所有AI时代
因为太容易爬你的数据了
AI做的这个程序
我都可以在网上到处乱爬
所以大家所有的传输
包括我们现在自己做高频交易
就是都是用cloth
就是我至少我传到
AWMX 语音肯定是用cloth
AWMX 语音网交易所传
那个是有加密的
就我们可能不用cloth
用影响速度
但是cloth也是基本上
是标配
但是它的那个需求很大
但是为什么暴跌呢
因为那个anthope说
新的模型可能对安全造成影响
就是大家不知道
你的现在的软件公司
做的那些安全东西
是不是在新的AI时代里面
会被AI攻击
因为AI可以
它大量数据的检索
可以找到你
你人类找不到的这些错误
隐藏了几十年的
这些Bug都会找到
而且最可怕的是
现在就算新的模型
Methios出来
就是anthopeMethios出来
就算这个新的模型出来很强
它还是B卡训练
它还不是英伟的
那个Valruin训练
Valruin后面还有新的卡
所以当一代一代
每一次几个月跌一次代
然后每一次都是
新能巨大提升以后
人类写的代码过往
人类手搓的东西
在那个机器面前的安全性
这个就是非常恐怖的
就是你表述三六的安全
就被垃圾了
这个没有用
就是在AI的这些攻击下面
所以大家对软件的质疑
也本质于来源于这个东西
软件的业绩本身有没有问题呢
没有任何问题
然后
软件业绩
其实软件业绩增长的变缓
跟AI现在关系不上它
就并不安全是因为AI
然后AI还是要用到这些SARS
但是工具它为什么不用
像Jason讲
我为什么做一套新的
可以用到这些工具
但是本身软件前几年增长很快
它的增速就在变卖
但是这个变卖时候
档口正好碰到了人家去讲AI的故事
所以你就会被砸很凶
所以这个是软件
所以今年的市场
其实你要去市场
再找一个AI的失败者
去年是找AI的成功者
谁可能贴上AI
你业绩好不好
没关系
先给你掌一波
然后今年是你先给你砸一把
然后你业绩好了
没用
你证明得了吗
你像NAT
你能证明你今年明年后年
三年五年以后
你还是能够在安全领域这么强
你证明不了
证明不了
先把你砸了
这个是今年的交易的趋势
所以我一直在说
今年的整个市场
如果说要投资的话
一定得跟算币增加直接相关
就比方说
我们刚刚讲到的半导体
这个是直接相关的
就是我就是
我所有你再强的东西
你前段是工厂
那你造机器的直接相关
我很快说一下
今天说一下AMD
你也说那个no care
可能来不及了
然后为什么说AMD
因为AMD的卡
就是它的算力的卡
是三家里面最差
它在去年今年初
屡次的证明了
就算它的卡送了股票
就算它的卡
这个就算它价钱
马卷都比那个英伟达低
它增速还不如英伟达
就因为咱们达70的增速
它到不了
它差远了
然后它的英伟达到75的马卷
它也到不了差远了
还是送了股票
它也不行
也就是说明
它远远不如人家
你作为一个追赶者
你这样就很尴尬
你怎么证明你能追赶它呢
所以它的股价其实压力
就是上次业绩之后
一直有压力
但是接下去可能情况会变化
因为Token的需求带大了
也就是英伟达的需求
早就报表了
就全卖完了
然后你如果说希望得到算力
你得把所有剩下卡全卖掉
也就是英伟达的卡和TPU的都卖完了
然后AMD作为被迫的选择
因为现在并不是缺电
美国不太确定
它的这个土建
土建的是远远超过卡
那现在最好的做法是
无论如何
只要买到它都把它放进去
所以GPU的算力
它的弹性会更好
对
它是最差的
它不可能撤得过英伟达
就是现在在Rack层面封装
它跟英伟达是没法比
而且可见的都没法比
然后因为把货也给卖完
把HBM也卖完
它不是一个compatible
但是它是一个很好的弹性
很高的标的
因为Token的需求太大
那么同样的道理
说几句那个关于Nokia
Nokia一样
Nokia的问题是
原来算力中心和算力中心之间的
传输需求没有那么大
然后因为AR的时代的变化以后
算力中心之间的传输需求
变大了很多
也就是本来城市之间
一条小路就行了
现在遭偷速公路
那么高速公路的陈建芳
其实现在市场上
只有两家CNN和Nokia
去年的订单
大概是五年周期
因为这个长距光传输的
这个周期单是五年周期的订单
是10个亿
今年是100亿
其实还没有我们完全不开心
然后在4月份开始招败
Google开始先招
然后到8月份大概结束
这个过程里面招100亿
然后CNN可能拿一半
然后Nokia可能会拿一半
所以你们不要看不起Nokia
人家做手机
说人家做砖头
它瞬间可以超过
你所有认记的手机
我说了苹果一万
所有认知什么小米
我把给你全部超过
因为现在的周期是端
它不是手机端
Consumer也来穿那个
不是不行
那个你做手机呢
没有小米
你你以前对黄人勋决认的
这么高光的时刻
黄人勋说
那个雷军V5
这个时代过去了
现在的时代在端口
所以它端的这个需求
非常明确
第二个
机站的电的应用
就是Nokia做机站
那机站电的应用
现在是可能8910是不用的
以后要把
也叫AirRound
就是好像Ginson最早提出来
包括英伟达他们提出来
英伟达投Nokia
就是因为这个原因
就是以后的很多的Infra的这个
就是Infra就是那个推理的需求
可以放到Nokia的机站里面去
那放到Nokia机站里面
可以把这个电应用起来
那相当于对Nokia来讲
我原来是一个房产成销商
现在我变房东了
我变成那个运营公司
变成Hilton
所以这个对它也是个Game Changer
它是一个有短期招标市场
没有Pricing
加上有长期这个AirRound的
这个需求的一个公司
所以我大概简单讲一下
这两个标志
然后因为今天时间
可能差不多了
我就不做Q&A了
然后我们下一周讲的时候
我可能再找两个其他标志讲一讲
以后就可以多评论九亚点
如果你们感兴趣
那个可以私信告诉我或者GMS
然后我下周再说
好吧
今天谢谢大家的时间
我就先不做Q&A了
拜拜